hier oder da was geht ab marx zusammen
mit sturm bachbett in den salat gebissen
ich habe meinen salat wissen wie findet
ihr das heutige spiel hatte eine runde
crazy lucky guy mode hier also vorsätze
schlag mehr instagram bilder machen ja
mehr instagram bilder in meinem fall ein
vorhaben ist ein bisschen mehr output zu
haben als die letzten wochen monate lief
laut politische da immer nicht zu super
fehlen ich viel getue also leute täglich
sagst du einzelgrab einen entzug im bild
ein tweet ein video täglich dass man
doch nach oben laufen kann ich es
durchziehen soll auf jeden fall [ __ ]
ich habe ich im letzten halben jahr so
lieben platz führt vom training her
stimmt ich aber auch nicht so sehr ich
hab mich instagram hab irgendwie so 150
oder so leicht und das ist vielleicht an
früheren jahren machte das nie habe es
auch relativ spät erstklassig welcher
den sinn ich checke so müsse noch immer
nicht ich verstehe halt immer noch das
ist halt eine plattform ist die
unglaublich viele leute nutzen finde ich
voll okay also weil das ist halt ein
schönes bilderbuch oder manche machen
echt schöne bilder aber so keine ahnung
jetzt also ich mich wohler zeit dass es
so viele nutzen also instagram ist mit
abstand mein stärkstes
social-media-plattformen ding echte
stärker ist oder mit 400.000 auf
instagram rockt mit 150 beiträgen oder
so und macht da täglich ganz viele
abonnenten dazu ich weiß nicht warum
weil die sind nicht lustig die sind
nicht gut ist alles am handy gemacht
gibt er nie was nachbearbeitet
vollkommen krank doch cool
ja ich feiert ist auch man würde aber
ich verstehe es nicht ich finde die
twitter ist aber so bisschen
persönlichere kommen
aber bisher crazy das kataster da ich
finde dass ich finde das cool natürlich
aber also ich verstehe es nicht wurde da
letztens auch gefragt da ich mit leuten
von von einem diversen netzwerk
getroffen war auf tag essen und an
meinten die sowie würde nicht gerne mal
fragen wie du das eigentlich mit deinem
instagram account marge weil da geht ja
schon ab und habe ihnen gesagt keine
ahnung habe dann gesagt ich glaube
instagram liebt mich einfach nicht
glaube dass mein großes geheimnis dann
gebe ich wenig darüber was ich da und
bahn hochladen aber du hast gerade
gesagt lustig mit dem aufnehmen
mittagessen getroffen
es ist nicht komisch auch nur auf einem
mittagessen zu sein
waka waka teufel ja okay ganz in ordnung
wir werden jetzt probieren zu gewinnen
weil wir sind zu finden wir zumindest
ich hab dir gott erklärt haben ein super
super duper team findet ihr das auch
lasst ein leichter blas protection kommt
wie findest du mache ich das so mit lex
klären und so laux klären es geht
einfacher leute lasst doch einfach mal
10.000 likes da wir machen das fertig
hast du noch emmerichs wild und laut
du hast noch zwölf übrig revieren
geworfen muss jetzt wirklich aber ich
hab schon ab 12 schwert ok wird macht
macht du die rein machst du dir am
besten science also kauft möchte
zusammen genau dann starten wir beide
mit schafen zwei das ist schon wo alltag
für die maschinen wie sehr wir haben so
viel schlaf bekommen ja krank wir sind
auf jeden fall ein alter ab sechs gold
durch ich stehe auch gerade nicht warum
wir so viel haben aber in der höhle war
auch echt viel hier maler weise bauten
sind wir eigentlich dafür bekannt dass
wir so unmenschlich schnell die sachen
abbauen
wir haben sie jetzt vorliegt zunahmen
immer noch durch ihre sachen wir sind
halt einfach nice schnell margarine
leichter maschinen was sie schon hinter
dem wasser teilte was ja was du
anscheinend schon
ja ich glaube michael kommt zum beispiel
hoch ich muss noch passieren mir
allerdings zu machen ein blauer 2 es
wäre noch fast zu kurz
ich mache mich selbst ein paar 2.212
hielt forschens und gold apple
ich komme da links oder abhängen wir ja
hier bei dem das amtl
er kommt nie so super gutes zeug was man
mir nicht nicht breaken
ja das ist super hier gehen vor zu denen
sie das lästig der stick hat gleich nur
noch wächst hier deshalb gut wenn du
begrenzt und im bogen kämpfen
hier kommen greifen die trc anbieter auf
ich passe auf einer ist ja kommt an den
wänden das finde ich ein bisschen es
sind haben wir uns auf jeden fall schön
gewollt kopf fabisch aufschwimmt sehr
gut
ich komme auch apple lockt action swifts
ort hatte einer von dem verstehe ich und
du kommst in block b war ja schon 2x
trainer timo glock sind die souffleuse
block sind diese technik sachen so blöd
aber bitte keine jessica chastain chefs
runden dieses sofort er ich hatte noch
zwei mann ist um die zusammen ich hab'
ich habe aber noch eine kann protection
drei machen oder stück gar nicht
gebrauchen wir sowas ist die frage noch
jemand tatsächlich ist der schnelle
downloads zu punkt kannst wenn man nicht
richtig
mein kopf nein kommt mein kopf und mein
kopf mainstraße meinen kopf bleibt da
kommen mein kopf
minecraft meinen kopf beim einkauf mein
traum hast du noch ein schatten
ich glaub ich hab alles erstmal levels
die roten schuhsohlen neues okay das
natürlich ziemlich cool habe es drei
feier aspect online armor blogger und
manager ist hier bittet für dich
so hat er jetzt hat mein bruder
festgestellt du hast immer ja dieselben
sachen und wenn du zwei blöcke
hintereinander macht immer echt dass ein
fehler irgendwie ab da kommt einer davon
bist du blind bei mir oder ohne
überhaupt nicht schlimm
wir sind aber nicht schafft ihn glaube
ich auch allein haken hinter die hinter
mir ich habe der feier aspect raus
helfern das denn das teilte der svs
beschwert ja also oder
höchstwahrscheinlich noch gleich
geschlagen haben player täter konnt ich
hab sogar noch ein player positiv
wir holen uns die wir sind sehr gut
jetzt sind sie alle
wenn wir jetzt den kopf und sein kollege
ich hab noch ich habe noch viel
passieren jedoch nicht geht auch nicht
gezögert weil das wurde gerade richtig
vfa kalter ich bin auch richtig an von
möbel berlin gewünscht der mitte müssen
aus der mitte müssen uns damit ja ich
komme schon wo bist du
leute ich will auch mal laut mal nach
rechts hast du bald apple hier ich habe
auch noch ein player wie ich habe selbst
20 stück menschen also ich finde ich
bräuchte kurz hast du level picasso
freimachen ich habe nämlich nicht so die
super level 1 dann brauch ich mal kurz
einen schub händler erfahren ist ja noch
lang ist hier in der mitte schnell hier
also in die mitte gehst du das leben
aber gar nicht mehr so viele leute ist
leben als sie noch so lange ich noch
level kriegen kann ich mir erstmal gut
alles in spanien gilt die da vorne waren
wie gewisse etwas auf das würde ich das
bin ich da nicht so schlimm wenn ich da
jetzt so you know
das ist keine zehn level fahren oder mit
scheinbar ist immer noch nicht da nur
mit quadro blue israelitischen laut
einer studie
ja ich hab die schongauer maschine man
tut was man kann
ich suche aber einfach mal interessiert
ich liebe diese runden wo man wo es
einfach so läuft dass man so einfach so
ganz casual to machine von wegen einfach
weiter da kommt ändert das war das was
wir das auch gelassen
er hat mich alter der hat mich komplett
zerstört ein bisschen überrascht ja ich
hab's überlebt
ich bin auf einem baum gelandet so
walter ich habe nicht getötet
durch die explosion wurde gar nicht dass
das geht ich dachte okay sie gewonnen
jetzt aber genau das ist ja das ist sie
aber auch im leben alter hat er noch
eingesteckt dem spiel ja schlecht dass
leute ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen ich
fand es sehr nice sehr hektisch und
unkoordiniert aber dafür gut so wie man
die runden von sturm ihr und mir okay
ich würde nichts erspart
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen dann bis
zum nächsten mal tschüss